haha the Joe Rogan experience that's why
working at it software and he totally is
the guy and along with the rest of him -
like Romero and those guys like the that
group [ __ ] that should I know him do you
know John Romero I've met him a couple
times you know daikatana game he took a
lot of [ __ ] for that game that was a fun
game yeah yeah it took way too long and
there was a lot of bugs in it and all
that good stuff but dude I played it
when it came out I was like this game is
[ __ ] badass it and yeah I mean that
guy is - all of them
they're there they're like the Beatles
you know what it was like daikatana was
like the physics of quake 1 but with the
graphics of that era
see if you find a video of daikatana
in-game it was a fun game and I was like
this might catch on but people were down
on it before it ever came out there's so
much [ __ ] talk about it because it took
so long and cost so much money and they
had these giant offices in Dallas with
this huge penthouse yeah they're
spending so much money I personally
think they some of the best work that
they yeah it's this is a this image
right here is dark yeah this is not the
best video in terms of like what you're
able to see in-game stuff yeah there was
a lot of hype and certainly this is
another other video because that's like
so dark can't see anything
is that it I was lying yeah on the
Internet
I think the best work that they did was
when they were all together
yeah like keeping the band together
mm-hmm that honestly it's making games
is definitely a team sport
and and you got to have everybody
working together really well if you want
to pull it off we also have to have like
Division one pro athletes oh yeah Pro
you know I mean rockstar vision ones on
a good I did like your if you're gonna
make it game you need everybody to be a
the same level of dedication same level
of hardwork to say rockstars yeah one of
the siz it this is why is he
sword I've never saw this usually it's
like what is this I don't think this is
the game dude it's not a good time no no
this is not it might be a mod I mean
maybe it's mod I never saw it like that
what I saw was a lot of cool rocket
launch like this is one rocket launcher
that would shoot and it would come out
like DNA strands shara shara the rocket
with like two Rockets would twist at the
same time they go back and forth yeah
this is what the game looked like it's
just just really dark for some for
whatever reason huh maybe like some
levels you get a sword I never saw it I
never saw this either this looks weird
I think this is the game oh yeah I think
so too I've been [ __ ] forever since I
played it I know that Romero likes what
we're making which is a huge compliment
what is he up to now
I don't know he lives in Ireland I think
what yeah I think so and and but when I
met him he was a super nice guy
[Applause]